welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul aka the guy who's a demon
in the sack in this video we're breaking
down the new Game of Thrones spin-off
and Knight of the Seven Kingdoms
recently announced the social media team
behind the show been slowly putting out
teasers and we recently got a title
reveal over the top of a map what
exactly is the show and what can we
expect to see in it well that's what
we're going to be breaking down in this
video so come join our house as we get
into what the premise of the book is and
also talk about everything we know about
the show so far this will probably
contain spoilers but I'm gonna try and
keep things centered around what the
show is rather than what the big debts
are if you enjoy the video then please
hit the thumbs up button and make sure
you subscribe for videos like this every
day without the way huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into a night
of the Seven Kingdoms and the book
itself was released back in 2015 and
it's basically a collection of the first
three Duncan egg stories by Georgia or
Martin the first one will be centering
around was the first published in 1998
but they were all brought across in this
short collection now these are called
the swan sword the mystery Knight and
the first of these witches titled the
Hedge Knight that is the book that this
series is going to be based on with its
full title being and Knight of the Seven
Kingdoms the Hedge Knight gonna be the
longest title ever and a nightmare for
my YouTube tags but this narrows it down
to what this series is gonna be about
now this is set roughly 90 to 100 years
before the events of the original Game
of Thrones and it's sandwiched right
between the events of House of the
dragon and got all this stuff with her
an era happened 200 years before the
emergence of Daenerys so we are kind of
getting this stuff in between the pad
things out and imagine that the cat's
board dagger pops up at some point and
we can kind of see how it ends up going
from House of the dragon and then into
the main series now I did say this
wouldn't spoil any of the big deaths but
we do need to talk about one in order to
kind of set up what the premise of the
show is the story really kicks off when
a hedge Knight known as Sir Island Penny
tree dies and then from here his Squire
dunked aside to take over the reins and
work his way up to competing in a
tournament as a night taking siren's
armor horses and everything he left
behind dung sets out of Ashford which is
where the tournament will go down along
the way he meets a character called egg
who he takes on as his Squire egg is
called egg because he has a shade head
and therefore he looks a bit like an egg
see that's how you get dunk an egg and
this video is sponsored by dunking eggs
you son of a [__] I'm in I haven't
actually seen a knight's tailor I
haven't seen it but it's one of those
films where I feel like I can't imagine
the plot and what I imagine it to be is
basically that now upon reaching ashware
dunks actually turned away because he
can't really prove he's the Knight
however bailar Targaryen steps in and
then he vouches for him again haven't
seen it just imagine something like that
happens in that movie let me know in the
comments below that it doesn't because
it probably won't but yeah that's what I
imagine the tournament's a big event and
I I kinda expect it to rip on the one
from the main series and House of the
Dragon if you cast your mind back to how
the mountain made his debut then he did
it by killing a horse after losing a
joust the event has a similar thing
happen with Aryan Targaryen going crazy
over losing and in his frustration he
kills the Humphrey honding's horse this
causes a lot of games because it's a big
No-No when it comes to Etiquette now
that night Aryan ended up being a usual
typical Targaryen and he beat up a girl
which caused dung to LEAP to her defense
she was a puppeteer and she plays a big
part in the story with her being the
apple of dunk's eye as during this fight
we get one of the big reveals with egg
and we learn he's actually aryan's
brother also might be pronounced Aryan
but moving on it turns out that the
shaven head was done for a specific
reason which was of course the hide his
classic Targaryen locks egg Targaryen
and you can kind of see where that's
going as egg goes on to be egg on the
fifth everything kind of ramps up to a
big battle between Duncan Aryan which
will likely be what this entire series
is centered around now there's lots of
things they can do with the series and
though it's probably going to be a short
limited one you never know the dance of
the Dragons actually doesn't go over
that many chapters and we've seen how
they've turned that into a big season
spanning series I think what will likely
happen is that if this series is
successful then they'll probably adapt
the other books that pop up in the
collection unfortunately this is gonna
be a show that's hit by the writers
strike on a blog post I dropped April
17th George RR Martin said that writing
was well underway during this he
revealed that the pilot script had been
completed in full and that the rest of
the series was currently being worked on
however it wasn't too long until the
writers strike here and this has slowed
everything right down dropping another
post Martin confirmed the entire
writer's room had been closed and that
it would be shut down for the entire
strike so depending on when we get the
resolution to this all depends on when
the show is gonna be resumed they then
got a right cast builder sets film edit
and so on it's gonna take quite a a
while and I was thinking that the show
would be released at the end of 2024
potentially however with the delays
being ongoing I think that is probably
going to be 2025 at the very earliest it
all depends when things get worked out
by and at the moment there's also rumors
that sag could go on strike too then
come next year we are going to see a lot
of delays and coming off the back of the
pandemic means it's been a rough time in
Hollywood I think with the release of
this they might also do a thing to fill
in the gaps between the house of the
Dragon Seasons which to me would be the
smartest thing to do so even if it was
ready by 2024 they might not want to
drop it due that probably being a house
of the Dragon year Disney to me have
been overdoing it with their multiple
releases yeah and I've noticed that it
does kill the interest in the show with
House of the Dragon Seasons taking about
two years to make they'll probably do
that one year and then potentially
alternate with the rest of the Knights
of the seven Kingdom collection a
Georgia R Martin has also teased there
might be more Duncan egg stories coming
down the line on his blog he said before
we reach the end of the published
stories I will need to find time to
write all the other Duncan egg novellas
I have planned just finish the main book
first mate foolish get the main get the
main one done
anyway that would mean that they have a
lot of things to pull from so this could
even be a four or five season show that
goes beyond just the three Novella by
then they might also have the rumor Jon
Snow series set up and we could get
three Game of Thrones titles running
concurrently I think it might get to
that point too as House of the Dragon
was big business for HBO and The Game of
Thrones Universe has gone back to being
that Flagship title so good everyone
forgot about season 8 which means it has
to be one of the best shows of all time
now we could also use this as a
springboard setting things up like the
Mad King and though that wouldn't be out
for a while this show could explore the
constant in breeding that eventually led
to his creation the targaryens still
hold the throne at this point but we
could continue to see the seeds being
sewn that caused it all to come crashing
down I actually think that's a great
idea to set up these two characters in
Duncan egg and then we could follow them
through their lives and see what they
get up to they could do something like
the Mandalorian where it's a Lone Wolf
and Cub series which I think has an
aesthetic that would be perfect for this
show they may even link things together
with the house of the dragon and Duncan
egg series where we see some locations
being smashed up in the past and then
revisit them further down the line to
learn about what happened in the
aftermath just hope Geoffrey doesn't
show up and drop some big spoilers
because he actually ruined the end of
House of the Dragon if you if you go
back and watch the main show and I'm not
gonna spoil it here but genuinely he
ruins the entire thing because he's an
absolute [__] mate anyway let me
know your thoughts in the comments below
are you excited for the show do you want
things to just go back to normal with
the writers strike yeah it's all a bit
all kind of up in the air at the moment
but I love the thoughts on it now last
month we also ran a competition giving
away a copy of the quantumania steel
buck and the three winners of that are
on screen right now if you want to
support the channel for as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below and as a thank you you'll
get access to early videos every week me
and Greg from real rejects have also
just launched a podcast which goes over
movie and TV shows every single week
First episodes out now on Spotify Amazon
YouTube and apple podcast so if you want
you just want to kill two hours well you
know you're going for a walk are you
going for a run you're going to bed at
night you want something less do then
definitely go check that out right after
this you answer me I'll still watch you
have another Game of Thrones video on
screen right now where we go about
what's happening in House of the Dragon
season 2. there's been lots of behind
the scenes stuff shown so definitely
head over there right after this by the
way huge thank you for staying through
the video I've been your host Paul I'll
see you next time take care peace